the Chicago Republican Party is filing a
lawsuit over these walk outs from the
Chicago Public Schools and to tell us
why is the chairman of the Chicago GOP
Chris Cleveland and also joining us is
jitu Brown the National Director for the
journey for justice Alliance one of the
organizers of the walkout gentlemen it's
great to see both of you let's start
with you Chris
the lawsuit has not yet been filed I
understand although you did file a
complaint what is the beef I mean these
kids are just organically getting
together and expressing their First
Amendment views well that's not exactly
what the situation is though the nature
of our complaint where the Inspector
General's Office was that these teachers
and administrators in the public schools
we're using taxpayer dollars to advance
a political agenda now that's not just
distasteful it's not improper I mean
it's not only improper it's it's illegal
to it's contrary to Chicago Public
Schools rules it's contrary to Illinois
state law that says that you can't just
write taxpayer checks to political
movements and you know it's arguably a
violation of their their First Amendment
rights because there's kids who are
coerced into doing this you may not
agree
jeetu I understand that the children who
did not want to take part in the walkout
were instructed to they could gather in
a classroom they could they didn't have
to hear it they didn't have to go to it
but classes were canceled during this
period of the school day why is that
good for the kids today who need frankly
more classroom time and more focus on
their studies I think that we have to
remember that one of the things that
education has to be is relevant and so
we talked about what makes good
education that means a curriculum that's
rigorous a curriculum that's relevant
and a curriculum that engages young
people in a way that's creative and in a
way that inspires them so I think when
young people have real-world issues
about like being afraid of being killed
in their neighborhood or being afraid of
being killed with someone bringing an
automatic weapon into their school
that it is not about a partisan issue
it's about young people and I know the
young people that I engaged with who
were passionate about letting their
voice be heard during this time they're
young people from my community who have
been working on issues like this for
years and I think you know have not
received the support from mainstream
media that young people from parkland
received but I know that this was not an
issue of at least from the young people
and the people that I've engaged with
this is not about young people being
parroted or manipulated by adults I
think that's kind of insulting we have
to remember that you know there was a
time when you know you couldn't host a
show like this there was a time when I
couldn't sit on a TV channel like this
and there was young people who pushed
the establishment to say this is what
the moral issue of the day must be right
so g2i I hear what you're saying
my concern is and my point and the angle
was the idea that this is just a bunch
of students getting together and this
was all students right well to some
extent there were some students I
obviously have heartfelt views I get it
it's not about whether you have the
right to protest it's about whether
schools should be used to advance a
political agenda and it is a political
agenda that a lot of parents and a lot
of students do not feel comfortable with
and feel excluded from and I don't think
gee - you probably would have been all
that thrilled if the March was an
anti-abortion March that students were
encouraged to attend there were things
sent around like this email from an
elementary school teacher in Chicago
yesterday feel free to join in the
morning from 10:00 to 11:00 a.m. outside
for a walk out and informative action
you are more than welcome to spread the
word to tell family friends in the media
Sara faller middle school literacy
teacher Jonathan Berg elementary school
I don't think if that agenda was a
conservative agenda or a pro-life agenda
would have all this woo from the
mainstream media interviewing them
putting them on TV do you think that
well I would say if you if you thought
that I was going to come on this show
and say that this is a report
like an issue then you're mistaken I
think that the issue the failure to
address the the gun violence in the
United States is a bipartisan failure is
it a failure by Democrats or Republicans
so for those who stood outside with
young people today the work is not
finished
chiju you didn't answer my question yet
you said it was good I'm not even saying
it's a Republican thing I am saying it's
political and if this were a massive
push for a pro-life rally that was
nationwide pushed by the Catholic Church
or other organizations that weren't
political I do not think would have
groups allied with the teachers unions
and other organizations
cheering the students on I think that
say well a lot of kids don't agree with
the pro-life thing a lot of kids are
pro-choice why would you push that there
have been 55 million babies who were not
not born in the United States because of
that movement that's a lot of blood
bloodshed but I don't think that a lot
of people would be thrilled about that
so Chris you want to file a lawsuit
perhaps it does seem to be contrary to
the policies that I've read in the
Chicago School District but nevertheless
this is a very popular movement I think
g2 is right gun violence is a big
problem in Chicago we've had a lot of
lives lost and there are a lot of
different solutions not just grabbing
guns but there are a lot of different
solutions that are being embraced by
students well I don't know but that's
actually the case I mean what I'm seeing
here is coercion I'm seeing that the
kids are being encouraged to fill out
these posters and go out and protest and
urge their congressmen to vote for
stronger gun laws and this business that
they're not being coerced is absurd I
mean kids in in our elementary school I
actually became attuned to this because
I received an email from our principal
at our elementary school kids ages in
grades 5 through 8 we're being herded
outside to do this here we get 10 12
year old kids who are told that if you
don't want to do it you can go sit in a
room by yourself and all your friends
are gonna be outside doing this I mean
this is straight-out coercion and it's
straight-out a left-wing agenda so it's
crystal clear that it's paid for by
taxpayer dollars
and this is improper g2 yeah I mean I
think it's an insult to young people to
say that in order for them to raise
their voice in a way that it's
passionate that is clear that somehow
they have to be manipulated by adults I
remind you I'm so I will say this I'm
not in every classroom but I will say
this the overwhelming majority of young
people that you see speaking around the
country the young people in Chicago who
walked out of their schools and then
went to the mayor's office on a Democrat
exposed in school skills to get jobs and
to be independent adults I mean and
civic know city schools away young
people are together so I'm not
advocating for like daily walk outs but
it when issues become when issues become
critical when issues become critical and
young people are screaming to us whether
it is the gun violence in the street or
whether it's new gun violence in their
schools and we and we are suffering from
inertia it is not our place to say
whether they are correct the incorrect
are you saying our young adults do not
have a role in guiding the the actions
of young people is that what you're
saying I never I never said that
what I said was that when when adults
have failed to address quality life
issues for young people and young people
raised their voices up right so do you
think that the people who worked at
Woolworth's liked it when young
african-americans and white children sat
in idly 700k that that issue
and relevant activism g2 and Chris I
celebrate political actors I think it's
awesome and I think a lot of kids were
excited and they think they're you know
their voice are I get that we're talking
about it's a political issue and it's
being pushed by political groups that
have an agenda and Democrat politicians
that want to drive turnout that was my
point it's not all political activism
it's great but this is a school day kids
got to learn kids got a lot to do and a
lot of kids don't agree with it and I
think that's intolerant to make all kids
feel like they have to take part in this
or no they're not part of it I know
young I know young people that should I
know young people in Chicago did not
walk out and nobody pressured them
nobody nobody does nobody criticized
being pushed I think a lot of people
would claim they were excluded and they
felt like it was an intolerant
atmosphere that's why schools can't
become political because people disagree
on these issues they're very complicated
constitutional laws involved I was 12 I
didn't know all that much about
constitutional law but you know maybe a
lot of the kids today know a lot about
constitutional law that I didn't know
guys great conversation we're gonna have
you on for an hour thank you so much for
joining